If my house tested positive for mold, should I buy an air purifier?
Somebody asked me this question a couple of weeks ago because they saw an air purifier that said it removes
X percentage of biotoxins, or, excuse me, micotoxins.
And you know, micotoxins are toxins that mold produce. I just don't know how you could actually measure it.
Yeah, the percentage of micotoxins removed by an air filter. So again, I'm sorry, a Mr. skeptical,
but I would throw a giant red flag of skepticism about a claim like that. But could an air purifier
actually remove micotoxins? Sure, an air purifier could remove things that are in your air space.
So absolutely they can. Can an air purifier kill mold?
No. So can it trap mold spore? So understand, an air purifier draws air through it and then it has
some sort of filtration system, many times several different types of filtration. And then the air goes
through it and goes out cleaner than from the back side. So that's how an air purifier works.
Will that kill mold? No. Could it trap mold spores? Yes. Could it trap micotoxins? Yes, good. So
would an air purifier be good if you have mold in your house? Sure, could be. Yes.
If you want to try to help kill mold, then you have to use an air ozoneator.
So an air ozoneator is created as just an ozone creator. And ozone is O3. Ozone is heavier than
O2. Therefore, it'll drop into the air space. And ozone will be quick to donate an oxygen atom to
anything that it comes in contact with. And if it came in contact with a growing mold on your
side of your wall in your basement, well, then that extra oxygen would kill that mold. So an
ozoneator will help kill mold in a space where there's mold that's visible. So that's where
the difference. So an air purifier, quote unquote, that is an ozone creator, ozone producer will help
kill mold. But will that dock? Will that kill micotoxins? No, nothing will kill micotoxins. They're
not living things. Will that kill mold sports? Yes. Because if it attaches to it, it'll definitely
kill mold sports. Will it kill mold on the wall? Yes. If it attaches to it, it'll definitely kill
mold on the wall. That thing is going to kill micotoxins because they're not living air purifier
filtration system may trap some micotoxins. So just understand, you have to be buyer, beware about
oh, I'm stuck. I don't want to sound like I'm so stinkin' cynical, but there's just a lot of
incorrect stuff told to us that to get us to buy something. And I think we just need to be
understanding before we get trapped into a sales pitch that isn't necessarily true.